their presence
shows our joint commitment
to
fighting for our joint values and to
intensify our parliamentary cooperation
and to introduce ukraine on the path to
europe
especially
mrs arena now two minutes please
thank you president commissioner
we
bear witness to a tragic fact every day
in the world there's a proliferation of
war crimes maritime and territorial
aggressions
and systemic violations of fundamental
human rights russia's attack on ukraine
confronts us with this reality
the horrors lived through by the
ukrainian people in spite of their
formidable resistance and the serious
violations of international humanitarian
laws are producing massacres rapes and
kidnappings and i think they're clearly
crimes of war crimes against humanity
and genocide
as we have heard these crimes cannot go
unpunished we need to establish
the collection of evidence
all the evidence the international
criminal court needs to have as many
elements as possible for it to be able
to successfully carry out its
investigations
but in addition the international
jurisdictions need to be able to
deal with the case as well unfortunately
the crime of aggression is not one that
the court is competent for so we need to
fill that gap by creating a special
tribunal which would have the remit of
judging rush the russian authorities for
this crime of aggression
the fight against impunity is urgent and
crucial
this
is something that's necessary for the
security of the world and the survival
of peoples who should not be governed by
the laws of the jungle thank you
thank you mrs arena now mr tudor for one
and a half minutes please
dear president
dear commissioner
dear colleagues
war is back in europe in its most
dehumanizing form a war
which has gone past the battlefield past
tanks and guns
past any logic of combat
people queueing for bread are shot dead
families
waiting for a bus waiting for a train
are being bombed children
are being raped women are being raped
old men
are being raped
all these people are innocent
their lives shattered their livelihood
being stolen
these are barbaric acts part of a
sinister vision of the world that seeks
to systematically
break down the will
and the identity of a free nation
we must fight for justice to these
victims of war crimes we must work with
international institutions with
national authorities with civic
platforms to secure evidence and prepare
the framework for delivering
much needed accountability and i want to
thank you commissioner for the work that
you have done
with eu agencies mobilizing them putting
forward legislative frameworks to
prepare for that accountability impunity
is not an option putin must know that he
and his gang will respond for the
atrocities they've committed and they
continue to commit every day thank you
[Applause]
thank you mr tudorachi mr lagadinski in
our two minutes please
ukrainian friends
first and foremost
we owe you our support
in fighting back this war of aggression
that's why military deliveries
are necessary to fight back and to push
back
but in cases of murder rape torture
fighting back means for families of
victims for survivors
also the fact that
that perpetrators must be brought to
justice
this is why
it is important that any russian soldier
private
any commander
any politician in russia knows
that they
will be held accountable for their
crimes
if not today
then tomorrow
if not tomorrow then in the face of
history
in front of tribunals and in the history
books they will not be remembered as
glorious heroes but as criminals
who tied people's hands
behind their back
before shooting them
in the neck
we say to you
you will be
held accountable
wars are not a free pass for atrocities
even wars
have rules
and breaking them
is a severe crime
it's that simple
and that's why
we applaud the commission's efforts to
secure evidence
to support investigation teams and task
forces and we call on member states who
practice universal jurisdiction to
practices actively
and we call on those who don't
to join universal jurisdiction and to
support the international criminal court
eurojust and europol we owe it
to survivors
to the families of victims
we owe it
to ourselves
[Applause]
thank you mr lagadinsky one and a half
minutes now for mr madison
please
thanks so much mr
president mr commissioner first of all i
absolutely agree with everybody who's
saying that there has to be
responsibility for all the war crimes
and there's the responsibilities for the
political leaders but to take
them
to the court or take them
to really pay for the war crimes first
you have to win the war because without
the winning of the war there will be no
responsibility and to win the war
you just have to give so many weapons as
much as possible to ukraine because i
have to remind you
i have to remind you in last three
months from 24th of february eu has paid
50 billion euros for energy from russia
at the same time we have provided for
few billion euros
arms and military technique to ukraine
so it's not very well balanced
but of course i absolutely understand
it's difficult for germany difficult for
hungary we have to deal with this but
on the same time if we pay 50 billion to
russia we have to pay as much as
possible to ukraine especially with
weapons
second thing
everybody shocked about the war crimes
how it's possible 21st century
the problem is that russia hasn't
changed it's exactly the same country
the problem is that 1945
they did exactly the same war crimes
they raped on the same way they killed
the same way like today because they
didn't have to pay for the war crimes
because at this time of course the
common enemy was nazi germany
and the u.s uk france were together
allies with the soviet union and they
felt as a winner
and today i'm most afraid that we are
doing the same mistake because for the
last sentence when i heard last week
that emmanuel macron proposed to mr
zielinski that we need a piece and we
have to save the face of vladimir putin
i was really shocked and of course
macron says that no it's false but in
this case i believe more zelinski than
macron there will be no saving face of
aggressor and dictator we have to take
them back
thank you
mr madison
one and a half minutes now one and a
half minutes for mrs fortiger now
thank you president
colleagues
yes certainly for decades
russian federation was able to to turn
the attention of the west
from immediate neighborhood and
will to conquer neighbors
to
global issues
now
it is impossible
we are aware of at all atrocities
happening in
ukraine
during this
appalling
invasion
[Music]
that is
next stage of of the war that started in
2014
russia is to to be defeated in this war
and surely
no impunity for perpetrators of war
crimes and for
instigation
and decision makers
as well we require special tribunal and
we we require all actions that are
already taken i'm happy that my country
together with
ukraine and lithuania
were in lead of of member states
initiatives
to eradicate russian impunity in war
crimes
through decades thank you
[Applause]
especially thank you mr fortiger now for
one minute mr urban crespo
thank you president although
we've had three months of the illegal
russian invasion of the ukraine the
u
n
has said that since 2014 war crimes have
been committed in the ukraine
and the perpetrators have never been
convicted that's why we back an
independent investigation that will
identify and charge those responsible
i hope
that
we have to say that it's a bit of a
change to see people condemning war
crimes in ukraine here because we
condemn them no matter who commits them
let me remind you
here
that the us army
the
killing of the
death of a spanish journalist in iraq
has not been solved and julian assange
who uncovered war crimes is now going to
be tried and that people have committed
crimes in the civil war in spain and
nothing has been done about that
we see
this kind of barbarism and we shouldn't
be selective about it colleagues because
it only benefits and the microphone is
cut off
and responds thank you mr alvin
[Applause]
and now one minute
mrs donato
thank you president colleagues we all
want war crimes against civilians and
prisoners of war in ukraine not to go
unpunished but unfortunately this will
happen as it has his or two
with
no punishment for the
2014 odessa
massacre in which
in trade union house tens of men and
women were massacred and burned alive
and
in the donbass
where
according to the humanitarian un and
osce
missions ukrainians
massacred people
and now in the
dark is putin and the russians
but there is objectively responsibility
that can be ascribed to both militias
the eu must be credible in pursuing
justice and cannot if it remain if it is
unpartial
the leader it is backing is not immune
of
the crimes caused in the crisis with
russia that brought about this war
only
can
response be credible if this chamber
adopts an objective approach thank you
ladies and gentlemen
mr elaine asks one minute
ladies and gentlemen i know this is a
very emotional debate
it's about life and death and
guilt and
atonement but can i just say it's not
part of our
practice to allow applause or any other
response from the tribune
witnessed the atrocities committed by
russian armed forces against innocent
ukrainian men women and children and
these images speak for themselves even
when there are simply no words to
describe the horror they depict
there can be no impunity for war crimes
in ukraine the perpetrators must be held
to account and for that we need evidence
evidence that is collected on the ground
in ukraine as we speak
and we need to make sure that that
evidence is safely stored something that
is obviously not possible on the ground
in ukraine at the moment as the war is
still ongoing and therefore we fully
support the commission's proposal to
give europe or euro just a crucial role
in the collection preservation and the
sharing of such evidence we need this
and we need this fast we cannot risk
losing valuable evidence and this is why
our group will support the text as it
stands now we still believe
it would be even better to also include
the crime of aggression but for now
speed is of the essence so let's get to
work let's make sure that those
responsible are brought to justice thank
you
[Applause]
fin
thank you mr leonard now for one minute
mr sanchez
the attack on ukraine is the most
dramatic representation
of
the
contradiction between two different
models of society and i think
this has to be clear
now we
and here i include ukraine when i say we
need to be very careful in what we do
here we need to be decisive given the
seriousness of the facts but we also
need to be exemplary irreproachable and
transparent we need to be clear in what
we do because any error that we make in
looking at war crimes would be fuel
for the misinformation that's being
spread by russia with regard to the
western world and the war in ukraine
president
we
approved two years ago the creation of
an observatory on impunity the
commission has dragged his feet for two
years and has only come up with a study
in all that time now in this situation
this observatory that
we wanted to see created would have been
very useful the european union needs
this observatory and other tools which
may well not be permanent but could be
activated in situations such as that
we're seeing now thank you
sanchez
mr sanchez thank you and now for one and
a half minutes mrs chi
colleagues more than four months after
russia's invasion of ukraine started i
have to say i am still shaken when i say
out loud that there is war in europe
it sounds surreal
yet it's all too real and all too close
to us
and during these four months there have
been not dozens not hundreds but
thousands of war crimes documented in
ukraine perpetrated by russia
every single day civilians die women are
raped and families are dragged deep into
russia against their will never to be
heard from again
all across the country mass graves bear
witness to the unspeakable human
suffering inflicted on an entire nation
so colleagues this resolution is long
overdue this is just about time that
this house officially calls putin russia
for what it is a war criminal and war
criminals cannot go unpunished
so that's why we are calling for an
attack tribunal to prosecute russia's
crime of aggression and that's why we
will support the icc in his quest to
bring the perpetrators to justice and
this is why we have to seize russia's
frozen foreign reserves to finance the
reconstruction of ukraine
and once this horrendous war is over
once ukraine emerges victorious
we will be there to help in any way we
can
so let this document be a foundation on
which we can build legal precedence on
which the brave people of ukraine can
place hope that there is a word where
actions have consequences a word where
impunity is impossible
but let this also be a warning for the
council as well because without
meaningful further sanctions these
atrocities will continue we have to move
quickly with further sanctions because
let's not forget europe might not be
fighting this war but it's europe
ukraine has been defending from the
russian aggressor in the past four
months thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you mr president
those who have been injured tortured or
killed in the ukraine i'm talking about
civilians
will of course want to see the people
who did those things to them hold before
a judge the crimes are still being
committed in the ukraine they're used to
threaten they're used to humiliate to
injure and torture
particularly when it comes to women and
girls we're aware that sexual violence
rape
is a war crime but it's one that
very rarely
appropriate appropriately punished or
even
tried
this time we should make certain that
that doesn't happen that people don't
get away with the crime of rape
so we need to have real steps taken to
make certain that happens
[Applause]
thank you mr kunka and now for one
minute mr fest
president ladies and gentlemen uh guests
from ukraine war crimes are unacceptable
and must be investigated irrespective of
whether they occurred butcher mariopol
or kirkiff and irrespective of what side
they were committed by and of course
irrespective of whether
it was regular soldiers and militiamen
or mercenaries who committed the crimes
everything must be investigated however
this stance mix up the necessary
clarification and
prosecution of
the
perpetrators
with
a european stance an idiotic political
agenda the eu's not responsible for
investigation of war crimes and never
should be that should be independent
courts and we've got an international
court in the hague that does precisely
that
and should do here
we support the investigation of war
crimes but reject their exploitation
in favor of uh sanctions and an
expansion of eu competencies and only
for that reason will we vote against
this uh
motion thank you mr fest and now one
minute for mr vashikovsky
thank you very much president
first of all
i would like to state that i fully agree
with the position
that has been presented by commissioner
reinders
i would like to thank him
very much indeed for having said that
poland
is one of the first countries
that have started to investigate the war
crimes committed by the russians
this is not just the war of putin this
is the war of russia so russia should be
tried and
a decision has to be made
in the investigation process russia
broke international law we also have to
bring to justice all the political and
military decision makers the same goes
for propaganda
responsible politicians those who incite
to
crime and hate
but we also at the same time have to
support the uh necessary
we have to offer the necessary
technologies for example to follow what
goes on in the social media
also
dna testing kits that are so necessary
for performing autopsies
for the bodies of people who probably
died in war crimes thank you
very
much
ladies and gentlemen
today we are witnessing the
day 85 of the russian aggression
while we
having this debate the russians keep
attacking
civilian populations schools
hospitals the number of war crimes goes
up murders
rapes
it is
very disconcerting that
million
of ukrainians have been forcefully
deported to russia
half a million
to siberia and beyond the arctic circle
this information comes from president
zelinski the security service of ukraine
have informed that one uh thousand four
hundred
russians identity who have conf who have
committed war crimes is already been
confirmed so what we have to do is to
put all those people uh in a special
tribunal
to be tried for the war crimes
uh the victims and their families must
know that the perpetrators will be
persecuted and
prosecuted and tried
the atrocities we've seen in bushoy and
other parts of the ukraine committed by
the russian invasion force
bring
back to our minds
things we saw in chechnya syria and
other parts of the world
and they are a reflection of the
state
which is carrying those out with
impunity so we need to fight against
impunity that's why it's vitally
important that we provide
europol and eurojust with a mandate and
the requisite means so that effectively
and fearlessly they gather evidence and
that we support the icc in its actions
but that's not enough it's not enough
to look into crimes against humanity in
war crimes it's necessary necessary also
that the crime of aggression be tried as
well and that needs to be done in a
special court that's why it's vital that
the european union carries out a
leading clear role supporting the
new court the invasion court we need
also of course look after the victims of
women who have been raped and guarantee
access to abortion and protection of
their sexual and reproductive health
under conditions which and guarantee
their dignity thank you president
finn thank for our colleague
thank you mr sanchez and now for one
minute
mr asmani
the commissioner dear ukraine mps
we all have seen horrific images coming
from ukraine and still today reports are
coming in a widespread executions
rape and torture by the russian army
and it is our duty to help the victims
of putin's aggression and bring those
responsible to justice
a joint investigation team was
established by lithuania poland and
ukraine to investigate war crimes in
ukraine and it was joined for the first
time ever by the international criminal
court in the hague and we will vote
today on an extended mandate for urges
that will allow it to coordinate and
support such efforts even better and we
will support also the commission and the
commissioner in its efforts but the time
to collect and safely store the daily
terabytes of evidence is now and more
can be done
first we should channel and coordinate
efforts of all parties involved and to
avoid duplication the jet should be at
the center of this coordination second
more member states should join the joint
investigation team to improve the
collection of evidence and finally we
should make available more forensic and
digital experts for the ssc to support
its efforts on the ground
fintanka
unfortunately i can't see mr veimos so
for one minute mr capulias
[Music]
colleagues
it is important that resolution defines
the establishment of a special
international tribunal for the crime of
aggression committed by putin
establishment of such a tribunal will
serve not only international justice
but also will have a major political
impact on how the war will proceed
further
it will be a very clear signal that
community of democracies he has a
political will to go for the full defeat
of putin in his war against ukraine
the west will not be able to push
ukraine for beneficial to kremlin
ceasefire agreements and plan to return
to business as usual with a person whose
crimes of aggression are investigated by
special tribunal establishment of such a
tribunal to investigate putin's personal
criminal responsibility will put an end
also to their phone calls by some
western leaders to putin and will stop
concerns about humiliation of britain
international tribal will take care
about faith saving of mr putin and that
will be the biggest political benefit
from this initiative the political west
will be pushed to be united for the same
goal to defeat putin's fascism
let's remember collaboration with
international criminals also is an
international crime
[Music]
[Applause]
colleague thank you very much colleague
and now mrs caliorand one minute
thank you president commissioner
colleagues guests
ayla olga
yesterday a process criminal process
started in ukraine
against a russian soldier who murdered
civilians this is the way to go we have
to bring before quotes people who rape
and pillage in ukraine but we also have
to bring before
court bring to justice people who are
sitting behind their walls in kremlin
it hurts me to hear this debates about
how we have to help the say putin to
save face and to start
debating
european security after the war with
putin no this is not the way to go we
have to bring these people before court
as it was done with a soldier in ukraine
putin and his
accomplices deserve their own nuremberg
only then we will have stability in
ukraine
because only then can i be sure that
we will not be saying told you so in
this chamber and
this is what we owe to the ukrainians
slav ukrainian
fintank
colleagues
dear colleagues
the ukrainian colleagues
the war of aggression launched by putin
against ukraine is primarily directed
against ukrainian civilians making them
the main target
and instrument of aggression
the russian leadership and soldiers have
become the perpetrators of genocide and
face responsibility
it is only a matter of time before
justice is delivered
we must do everything possible to ensure
that the war crimes and crimes against
humanity
that have been committed in ukraine are
newly documented and investigated
the civilized world must send a clear
message to russia
war crimes will be punished and
there will be no possibility of
hiding colleagues i call on the european
parliament to become as fully involved
as possibly possible in investigation of
russian war crimes by organizing public
undocumented hearings with victims and
witnesses
let us support the ukrainians and their
right demand for justice
[Music]
dear colleagues
the courage of ukrainian nation is
admirable after the victory in brussels
we will have to build a monument to
ukrainians who
protected us from russian aggression
the ukrainians have deserved this
respect
the war crimes against
men women children and men i have no
doubt that the perpetrators will
face justice and also also those who
loot the cultural heritage sites and
museums and art collections also those
have to
stand in front of justice let's hope
that these pieces of art will not uh
disappear in private collections and
after the victory i hope russia will
return them to ukraine
war criminals are also those
who uh with uh
barbarism of
exterminate
archives the biggest seed
archive and collection has been
destroyed
many scientific and academic values have
been destroyed it's a crime against uh
humanity because the destroyed
scientific collections and archives are
lost forever they are lost for ukraine
and for the mankind
thank you
and now mrs guterland i cannot see
so for one minute mr getter
president commissioner colleagues
the barbarism that we're seeing
in
ukraine
isn't unfortunately anything new in the
21st century
let's recall what happened in aleppo
let's recall
what happened
right across
syria
which is governed by an ally of mr
putin's it was the same thing the same
thing
and that is
why today
when we establish
the basis
of
a
new international justice system against
war crimes because that's essentially
what we're doing
we are essentially expressing our
solidarity with ukraine and our
indignation
with what's happening we're also
remembering what happened in aleppo and
we're trying to prevent other crimes in
the future in other countries and other
continents
commissioner i think we're establishing
the basis
of a new set of actions from the
european against war crimes thank you
colleagues
the wills of justice are moving
but we need to make sure they are moving
swiftly
heroic efforts are carried out already
by both ukrainian and european
professionals to secure evidence of war
crimes in ukraine
and from ukrainians across eu member
states
these efforts deserve our utmost
political legislative and financial
support
victims of war crimes incredible
evidence in order to seek justice
we must therefore diligently support
appropriate mandates and resources of eu
institutions especially eurojust in
order to safeguard the analysis and
preservation of all evidence of core
international crimes committed by russia
against the people in ukraine
only admissible evidence gives due
process and justice a proper chance only
well-guarded facts stand a chance
against russian malign propaganda and
deceitful methods their colleagues
ukraine must win this war and russia
must face consequences for his
aggression there can be no impunity for
war crimes and we shall still we shall
stand by victims of this brutal attack
until justice is fully and duly served
thank you
[Applause]
thank you mr bill chicken now for one
minute mr glucksman
president commissioner systematic
violation people being slaughtered in
the street uh hospitals and other
buildings being leveled the russian
action is limitless
impunity
has existed for 20 years
impunity for the crimes committed in
chechnya
for the crimes committed in syria
for the crimes committed in russia even
the aims
in georgia have gone unpunished too
there is a
huge level of impunity surrounding the
russian army it must be shattered
justice isn't just what we owe to
victims it's also about preventing
tomorrow's crimes and therefore
it is also about preventing the
temptation
that exists in some categories to
envisage a return to business as usual
after the war
that cannot be discussed
we cannot
allow ourselves to be sullied
with
crimes against humanity and crimes of
war
putin belongs in a tribunal nowhere else
thank you
thank you mr glooks man and now for one
minute
mrs rodriguez ramos
who's responsible
ultimately responsible for this war
that's given so much regards to so much
suffering well the person behind the
military
might of a state who has planned and
ordered new military invasion against
another sovereign state that's article
8a
of the treaty of rome
that means putin and the
criminal
high command in the kremlin are
responsible for this crime of aggression
it's vital therefore that they don't
remain unpunished that's why we're
calling on member states to introduce in
their national law the crime of
aggression which is vital if we're going
to set up a special ad hoc court
to judge putin and his criminal
government colleagues we're all
condemning
putin or putin will condemn us
to the with the threat of ongoing war we
also need to make certain that the
people have actually carried out the
crimes and the rapes be punished this is
a
message to putin impunity doesn't last
forever thank you
[Music]
thank you rodriguez
thank you mr rodriguez ramos one minute
mrs picciano
butcher
the rapes carried out in ukraine
bombed out
hospitals the deportations of children
these are the horrors which we've seen
during
recent months
and
we can only call for justice for these
atrocities
which
go
further than any act of war you could
possibly imagine
as we've been saying for months this war
is
utterly unjustified
so i think it is time to call for
justice
and to prosecute
those
who ordered those crimes against
humanity to be carried out
just
a few
hours ago
forensic experts and investigators
started investigating these crimes
against humanity and this is the largest
team ever sent
out in the history of the international
criminal court and this colleagues is an
excellent start
there will be no peace and we will know
no peace
until
these terrible
war crimes that we're still
seeing taking place
have been punished that is our
commitment and our responsibility thank
you
thanks very much good morning everybody
we're now moving to the catch the eye
part of the debate
and our first speaker is lexman
dear colleagues every day we hear new
evidence of russian war crimes in
ukraine
military attacks including on civilian
targets rape torture mass executions
forced deportations looting and many
other barbaric acts continue be
perpetrated against ukraine and its
people
they remind us of some of the worst
excesses of stalinism
we must ensure that these crimes are
thoroughly documented investigated and
those responsible are brought to justice
that's why i welcome the setting of a un
international commission of inquiry and
the launching steps of the icc
prosecutor's investigation into war
crimes and crimes against humanity
however we must also do all in our power
to establish a special tribunal for the
punishment of crimes against aggression
of aggression
we are witnesses of the tragedy that we
thought we will never see and to which
we said never again unfortunately this
is not the case and we must do and stand
up to those seeking to suppress human
freedom and dignity it's our moral duty
thank you
thank you colleagues i do ask you to
stick to the uh
allocated time
uh next speaker
dominic chris deveza you've got the
floor
thank you president
and thank you to maria
arena sponsor of this resolution which i
wholeheartedly support in particular the
idea of setting up a special court to
try the crime of aggression
we don't want to take any ground away
from the international criminal court
we've asked for
financial support
for them and the foreign
policy instrument will be providing ad
hoc financing to the icc so it can
continue to investigate war crimes and
crimes against humanity but now
they aren't able to
try
and invest or investigate the crime of
aggression that's why it's important
that we have our
european court set up for this
also
i speak to
commissioner reinders directly thank you
for coming so it's vitally important
that we look at this proposal to set up
the special court as well as a
legitimate proposal so that we can help
rebuild ukraine using the assets of the
russian central bank
[Music]
thanks very
much
mr sinchit is our next speaker
[Music]
thank you chair i think it's high time
that the commission asks itself
uh to who is its policy towards youth
russia useful russian revenues have
doubled in the two times or in the two
months of war i'm talking about march
and april
so russia earned more than two billion
euro in these two months
and from the eu
it got 44 billion
and before it disamounted to 12
million this is going to continue
uh this money is going directly to the
russian government
it
in order to build other infrastructures
we will need years
and
russia and to make things worse
russia is now asking uh to
be paid
uh that the oil and fossil fuels is
bailed in rubble
and the member states are accepting that
i think that the commission should
analyze whether this policy is
counterproductive thank you
andrews barry
please
it's not a blue card president i've
sought a slot and catch the eye thank
we you to
our colleague
tumac
you've got the floor
thank you president thank you
commissioner
an 11 year old child
was
left without both legs after the railway
station
attacking
kraton tusk
and
her mother lost
her left leg for those crimes
justice for civilians
is needed
there
is a responsible party with a name and a
face
for all these tragedies in ukraine
there's just one name for that
responsible party which is putin and we
must do everything politically to bring
putin before a court of law to answer
for those crimes
otherwise we won't be able to protect
the values which underlie the european
union thank you
thank you
barry andrews now is our next speaker
thank you very much president
i once again i'm calling on the
commission to act on the call from this
parliament for an eu action plan on
impunity it was called for in a
resolution this time last year in the
context of a resolution in syria and
nothing has happened since and it is
critically important
for the very obvious reason demonstrated
by the caesar trials in koblenz that
each eu member state takes a very
different approach to principles of
international law such as
universal jurisdiction
in some member states they have a
different approach to immunities uh they
have different approach to the statute
of limitations they have a different
approach
uh to the type of crime that triggers a
prosecution
under war crimes so we need an eu action
plan on impunity that addresses the
fragmented the fragmented approach taken
by eu member states thank you
thank you mr andrews
charlie weimars is our next speaker
thank you mr president
putin expected a swift victory against
all odds ukraine turned the tide
with almost 12 000 russian war crimes
reported one wonders what is emmanuel
macron's and olaf schultz's top concern
holding war criminals to account no
both are desperately trying to get back
to business as usual
buying gas
selling arms
both want to help putin save face by
pressuring ukraine to cede parts of
their territory
with the french president consider
seeding the french west indies to putin
and his cronies to dock their yachts
would the german chancellor give a
bundesland to the russians
the french and the germans would never
accept that so why should ukrainians
dear social democrats of germany they're
liberals of france i will be frank your
combination of war crimes mean nothing
unless you change your government's
policy of rewarding the kremlin with
territorial gains from these very war
crimes mr president this is an unjust
war it must end in a just peace ukraine
must win thank you
thank you very much
final catch the ice speaker
manic bouts
jingle
thank you president
dear fellow meps russians on
are
perpetrating terrible crimes in ukraine
they are murdering people they are
destroying cultural heritage of this
country we have to do everything for
russia to pay for these crimes and we
have to remember about it when the
conflict will end that we may only lift
the sanctions where russian will pay for
these crimes well all the perpetrators
will be punished
russia needs to be
needs to surrender thank you
thanks very much indeed and now to wind
up the debate i give the floor to
commissioner reinders once again go
ahead sir
[Music]
thank you president
honourable members thanks for this
debate and thanks for the commitment
you've shown and your solidarity with
the people of the ukraine and that's
obviously something that's been clear
right from the start of the aggression
i'd like to come back to today's
priorities in terms of the battle
against impunity and touch on a few of
the things that we're trying to do
trying to promote to fight against
immunity first of all let me thank you
in particular for the efforts that
you've been making
to
examine
at express speed the idea of
re-wording euro just mandate
you're voting on this text today
and that shows a real commitment to make
effective progress because
the risk
grows every day that evidence that can
be used to try the people behind these
atrocities might be lost or destroyed
it's therefore vital
that we bring in this legislation as
quickly as possible given the situation
on the ground in ukraine the second
point i want to mention is support
for the ukrainian authorities i'm
thinking in particular about the
prosecutor general which
and the icc
when it comes to the international
criminal court a certain amount of
financial supports already been provided
by the eu or individual member states
and it's important that we continue to
see what the court is doing just as the
ukrainian authorities are doing i've
asked all ministers of justice in europe
to
look at what kind of know-how they can
send to the ukraine i'm thinking about
forensic experts
pathologists and there's also the
question of security because of course
the conditions there are extremely
dangerous how can also we guarantee
secrecy of communication between the
people involved in the enquiries on the
ground and the experts back home we're
going to continue to work to that end
trying to strengthen our approach to the
ukrainian authorities and the criminal
court
third point i wanted to mention
is this joint banking team
i said that this is the best way of
coordinating our activities involving
the authorities in the ukraine
member states who
have
volunteered to take part in the joint
inquiry team but also
the
icc
authorities that's the first time that
they've taken part in such an action i'd
also then like to call upon the member
states who are
launching inquiries in their own
territories
in terms of gathering evidence to join
the joint inquiry team it's the best way
of coordinating work between the various
investigators also let me confirm that
commission will continue to work
and leave no stone unturned in the
battle against impunity we're working
with other international partners i'm
thinking of the uk and the united states
but also
people in the g7 or governments in the
g7 who want to work along the same lines
i'm confident that we are setting up
tools which will allow us to battle
impunity effectively whether this
impunity
is going to be dealt with under various
separate headings that's mentioned this
morning
but we've also got the question of the
russian aggression in the ukraine we've
been gathering evidence about that since
the outset and we're going to do all we
can to make certain that those responses
will be brought to justice it might be
tomorrow it might be next month next
year
but we will not
stop
working at with member states and
reaching out to the international court
to make sure that there be a genuine
responsibility for the people
involved in war crimes crimes against
humanity or genocide as decided by the
courts and tribunals in the weeks and
years to come
thank you for your work we will i
promise keep our
shoulder to the wheel at the commission
[Applause]
thank you very much commissioner
commissioner ryder's comments
wind up that item on our agenda
[Music]